solo a Star Wars story flew a little low
at the weekend box office bringing in
just 103 million dollars over the
four-day Memorial Day weekend a huge
drop from early tracking which predicted
the movie bringing in 170 million
dollars or more it also marks the lowest
opening for any of Disney star wars
films even below rogue one the
franchise's first standalone film
telling the origin story of the title
smuggler solo should have been able to
capitalize on the legacy of materoa
become a huge box-office draw but there
are a lot of factors that contributed to
solos disappointing box-office
performance so let's take a look at the
real reasons the film didn't perform as
well as expected
Star Wars fatigued solo is the fourth
film to come out of the new phase of the
Star Wars franchise and the first did
not hit theaters over the December
holidays while this may have led to a
diminished opening weekend it also meant
that the movie hit theaters just five
months after the release of the last
Jedi making it the shortest window
between the release of two Star Wars
films to date this may have contributed
to some franchise fatigue while the
trilogy films have build-up to bring
fans in no matter when they come out the
standalone films have to find a way to
make themselves seem like must-see
entertainment rogue one came out a full
year after the last Star Wars film but
for solo it may have been hard to drum
up interest so close to the prior film's
release a new take Alden Ehrenreich
landed a difficult task of trying to
live up to Harrison Ford's iconic
portrayal of Han Solo and although some
have praised his performance others
don't think he quite lives up to his
predecessor part of the problem could be
the script which shows off a much more
optimistic version of Han than the one
audiences came to know and love in the
original trilogy in the role Ehrenreich
came across as charming and fun but also
different from Ford's version of the
character while it was probably smart
for the actor to not try to do a direct
impression it still might give some fans
pause to see Han before the weight of
the galaxy got him down production drama
good press is a key to a movie success
and Solo was plagued by negative rumors
after a rocky production which included
the firing of directors Phil Lord and
Christopher Miller Lord and Miller were
said to have encouraged more improv
and a different tone than the company
wanted for the movie so they were
replaced by Ron Howard
even though Howard is a talented
replacement the behind the scenes
turmoil associated with the picture may
have left a lot of fans skeptical about
the finished product and while reviews
for the film were mostly positive they
weren't as overwhelmingly favorable as
its predecessors even some critics who
said the film was entertaining also said
it covered old ground and didn't bring
anything new or different to the
franchise since word of mouth is
essential for any movie to succeed solos
ground campaign might have been damaged
by the initial bad buzz and ho-hum
critical reception holiday Hays Memorial
Day weekend used to be the reliable
start of the summer box office but its
grosses have been in a downward spiral
in recent years the last time the
weekend offered up a 100 million
dollar-plus opener was in 2014 with
x-men Days of Future past more recent
offerings like pirates of the caribbean
dead men tell no tales
Baywatch x-men apocalypse and
Tomorrowland disappointed in the same
release time period while big movies
like Jurassic world fallen Kingdom and
The Incredibles too are likely to save
this summer from being a complete
disaster
solo was stuck in a period that's been
growing consistently worse in recent
years making it the summer's first big
flop lingering competition most studios
won't dare to challenge a Star Wars
movie which is why it was the only major
release during its opening weekend
however the film still faced competition
from the second weekend of Deadpool -
and the fifth weekend of Marvel's
Avengers infinity war he's trying to
copy him
Deadpool 2 was initially set to come out
the weekend after solo but Fox later
moved the release so that it hit
theaters earlier and even though
infinity war has been out for weeks it's
still a box office draw solo might have
managed to earn the top spot at the box
office on opening weekend but the ticket
booth was still crowded with other
options that might have eaten away at
its profits international struggles
while overseas markets have been known
to save some movies from obscurity solo
doesn't seem to be resonating with
international audiences the film took in
just 68 million dollars in the
international markets after releasing in
all major territories except Pan
with an already large budget pushed
higher by the movies reshoots
international profits were important for
solo but it doesn't look like the film
will be able to turn there for relief if
it continues to flop domestically what
does the movies lackluster performance
mean for future Star Wars spin-offs I
got a bad feeling about this
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our youtube channel
let's check out all this cool stuff we
know you'll love to
[Music]